bonjour karine mosso bonjour maurice
viol temps bonjour toute la martinique
et en particulier bonjour aux françois
d'où je viens et je vais retourner
vous êtes la présidente du comité
martiniquais du tourisme merci d'être
dans son caddie ce matin avant d'aborder
votre fonction c'est de cette structure
du tourisme peut-être une réaction aux
propos de bruno nestor azérot le maire
de sète marie élue dimanche et et qui a
déclaré au moment de sa victoire qu'il a
fait un seul charniers avec un fred
barry jeunes avec daniel marie-sainte
est avec vous car ils mousseau parce que
vous aviez apporter votre soutien à le
de ses concurrents je pense qu au vert
en réaction à ce mot charmilles et
peut-être réaction oui des propos très
violents de la part de monsieur à 0 je
le rassure je suis vivante et bien
vivante et j'estime que nous sommes en
démocratie et qu' il faut un petit peu
de morale en politique il faut un peu de
moral et je suis très contente d'avoir
été il avait dénoncé la violence de vos
propos moment vous étiez avec un
monsieur cover je ne n'ai pas eu de
propos violents mais en toute démocratie
je suis allé soutenir une équipe qui se
bat qui s'est battue et qui continuera à
se battre
monsieur matte hainard est quelqu'un de
voilà d'honorables et qui a subi des
humiliations et avec i had mon plaisir
nous avons décidé de les soutenir et
menacé de retirer ses propos
ben écoute et il fera ce qu'il voudra
mais nous sommes en démocratie n'en
déplaise à certains
voilà voilà moi ce que je retiens de ça
c'est qu'il faut de la morale du respect
en politique est un peu de dignité
voilà car il nous faut nous sommes en
plein dans cette saison touristique
c'est magnifique de voir autant de
bateaux de croisière dans la rade de
fort de france et dans d'autres villes
escales savons nous tirer pleinement
profit de cette situation lire leur
appel aux dégâts des tempêtes maria et
irma sur d'autres îles de la région
alors ce que je voudrais dire d'abord
c'est que sans irma et maria nous avions
prévu une excellente saison pour les
croisières on avait déjà prévu 420000
croisiéristes contre 380 mille
l'année dernière donc la croissance de
la croisière continuer de toute façon
donc sans irma et maria on avait déjà de
nombreuses escales on était déjà bien
organisé on avait déjà bien travaillé
pour avoir si le social il faut le gérer
ce surplus il arrive il faut le gérer il
ya beaucoup de réservations on sera
entre 600 mille sept cent mille
croisiéristes ce qui est une manne pour
la martinique pour les martiniquais et
les martiniquais sur ses vraies france
les saints pierre et paul et trois ilets
et c'est vrai que nous travaillons je
vais dire c'est un travail collectif le
comité martiniquais du tourisme je salue
le travail d'ailleurs de mon équipe
le grand port qui a mis en place des
infrastructures
je dirais msc l'a reconnu ce week-end
les infrastructures hors pair et puis le
port bien sûr donc c'est vraiment un
travail d'équipé et nous travaillons
aussi main dans la main avec la
préfecture qui a aujourd'hui mis en
place une task force croisière et en
particulier pour la sécurité des
passagers nous avons beaucoup plus de
moyens on s'adapte on réagit mais on
programme trois exactement quand on n'a
pas l'impression que la nouvelle équipe
dirigeante au sein du comité
martiniquais du tourisme encore vraiment
imposé sa griffe
qu'est ce que vous faites on a résolu on
a plus qu imposer notre griffe on a
énormément travaillé on passe douleur ma
couleur c'est ça a été d'abord de mettre
en place un nouvel organigramme ça a été
long parce qu'il fallait recevoir les 70
personnes du comité martiniquais du
tourisme
ce nouvel organigramme et mis en place
depuis mai 2010 est donc il est
aujourd'hui opérationnel et je crois que
tous les professionnels peuvent
l'attester ils se rendent compte comment
on peut travailler aujourd'hui main dans
la main avec eux et d'ailleurs je salue
aussi le travail des professionnels du
tourisme
et puis oui cette griffe sais quelle
idée qu'on donne aux agents nous avons
des idées innovantes nous en avons on
serait riches en couleurs que vous
continuez surtout appliquer ce que une
autre karine karine roy camille avait
fait pas du tout pas du tout le travail
sur la marque m avaient été entamées
donc j'ai décidé de le continuer parce
que c'est une
qui a été travaillé par une équipe et
qui est pour moi une très belle marque
nous avons d'ailleurs gagné le premier
prix des trophées de la communication
jean baptiste et puis des projets nous
allons nous en avons beaucoup dont en
particulier le projet de faire un grand
festival comité martiniquais du tourisme
l'année projet nous revenons sur le film
lucien jean baptiste quel budget ce film
alors ce film est à peu près si on est à
peu près sur un budget de 250 mille
euros de 165000 où il voit la cinor 265
mille deux cent cinquante mille deux
cent soixante cinq mille euros
265 1982 euros et 83 centimes eh ben
vous êtes bien renseigné budget initial
de 150000 euros
oui le budget initial était de 150000
euros
mais nous avons eu berens finalement
l'ambition de faire un magnifique film
de prendre aux martiniquais lucien jean
baptiste qui est un cinéaste reconnu et
nous aurons connaissance qu'on paye
autant cette reconnaissance on l'appelle
on paye la qualité on paye aussi il vu
ce matin sur les compteurs youtube un
film sorti il ya deux mois que 8000 vu
j'ai envie de dire eh bien écoutez il y
en aura beaucoup plus parce
qu'aujourd'hui on nous devons avoir les
budgets pour que ce film soit utilisé
c'est le budget que nous n'avons pas en
fait pour l'on sait maintenant le film
en particulier sur les chaînes
nationales nationale sion de la
martinique il faut maintenant de budget
pour faire la promotion du film
promotionnel
alors non il faut maintenant d'un budget
pour utiliser le film mais en tout cas
nous en sommes très fiers c'est vraiment
le travail du comité martiniquais du
tourisme tout entier et voilà premier
prix ados cannes donc donc ils sont
livrés avec lucien jean baptiste vous
êtes en pleine orientations budgétaires
on rappelle que vous avez trois
commissions la production la promotion
le nautisme et la croisière
j'ai envie de parler parce que vous
l'aviez déjà dit dans ce studio
il faut aller chercher certaines niches
le tourisme culturel on en est où
exactement qu'est ce qui se fera qu est
ce qui se fait
on a envie de savoir ce qui pourra se
passer là bientôt dans cette danse est
dans ce secteur très précis du tourisme
culturel
alors nous avons effectivement trois
commissions qui fonctionne je dirais
très bien avec trois présidente diane
montrose louise tel et aurélie n'est là
le tourisme culturel
mon projet je le redis c'est un grand
festival surtout qui va être porté par
le comité martiniquais du tourisme
festival a marqué qui souvent se
chevauchent sont se font concurrence à
lui la sentence
celui là sera le festival de la soirée 3
et 2 leur festival
non il viendra pas écraser les autres
mais il sera le festival signature de la
martinique il fera venir de nombreux
touristes donc ça je peux vous l'assurer
et puis nous travaillons beaucoup sur la
gastronomie et le spiri tourisme et ça
c'est une niche que nous voulons
développer continuer de développer avec
tous les producteurs de rhum en
particulier dans sont à nos côtés
le tourisme de niche va se développer en
martinique le culturel le spiri tourisme
le tourisme d'affaires et sur le
tourisme d'affaires aussi et puis je
crois qu'ils ont on doit vraiment
capitaliser sur ce que nous avons je
dirais d'exceptionnel ce que nous avons
d'exceptionnels ici c'est vrai que c'est
la gastronomie dont le spiri tourisme et
nous en faisons vraiment une priorité
alors karine mousson se souvient de
paille de l'organigramme tout à l'heure
on se rappelle de votre coup de sang
lorsqu'il s'agissait de la direction de
la directrice des ressources humaines on
se rappelle également de votre coup de
sang concernant le budget alloué par le
parent par l'assemblée de martinique à
part de la collectivité territoriale de
martinique
le cmt de comité martiniquais du
tourisme ses 12 millions d'euros vous
vouliez de 2 millions supplémentaires
est ce que vous l'aurez écouter en tout
cas je fais tout pour les avoir parce
que je pense qu'on en a effectivement
besoin le tourisme pour moi et
effectivement le secteur qui est je
dirais le seul ouvertement maintenant
que vous dites que vous avez aussi
rébellion alfred marie jeanne va vous
les aborder comme une mouche qui écoute
et on verra où budget 2018 mais en
principe il devrait me les accords dits
oui parce qu'il sait et je lui montrer
que nous en avons besoin notamment pour
qu'ils écoutent tout le temps et qui
décident au dernier moment tout seul
diffuser ce film je continue à lui
expliquer la nécessité qu on essaie de
tenir entre vous et parce que vous
prenez la route pour cette marie par
exemple les soutenir monsieur cover vous
discutez bah écoutez nous ne sommes pas
allés à 5 marie ensemble mais nous
travaillons ensemble et moi je travaille
pour la martinique et pour l'intérêt de
la martinique au président yan
monplaisir et ça donne dieu leur
relation
mousseau marie jeunes écoutez c'est une
relation professionnelle je dirais entre
guillemets politique et la question
cela non pas du tout la vraie question
c'est faire avancer la martinique et moi
on m'a donné une responsabilité celle du
comité martiniquais du tourisme et je me
donne à fond pour que ça marche et je
crois que ça marche puisque je vous
annonce que nous allons atteindre les 1
million de touristes en 2010 est ce sera
le seul indicateur qu'il faut prendre en
considération c'est déjà pas mal
et puis la dépense aussi des de chaque
touriste que nous voulons faire
augmenter c'est pour ça que je motive
tous les mardis nikkei toutes les
martiniquaises à innover par ce qui aura
il y aura de quoi faire dans le sens
dans ce secteur il faut que les
martiniquais continue à se former à ces
métiers du tourisme et comptines
formation mais vraiment au niveau pas
seulement le strict minimum et plus on
continue à se former puis même au niveau
des croisiéristes on attend de
l'innovation nathan des choses
inattendues
justement c'est l'expérience qui compte
pour les croisiéristes donc plus on aura
des activités inédites je vais dire
mieux ce sera voilà et tout le monde
pourra en profiter
vous avez entendu ces critiques sur nos
jeunes qui se forment au tourisme et qui
partent et qui font des stages ailleurs
et qu'ils ne reviennent pas en
martinique
c'est aussi le boss s'attaquer à ce
problème oui mais je suis très optimiste
de plus en plus reviennent j'en ai reçu
encore une hier et ont plein de projets
je suis très optimiste pour l'avenir nos
jeunes se forment
ils aiment leur pays
on vit que le pays change et j'espère
que tout changera avec mercy karine
mousse ou que vous êtes la présidente du
comité martiniquais du tourisme et que
vous l'avez dit vous aurez vos deux
millions de budget supplémentaire merci
j'espère bien
[Musique]